ALEX DANILO: The
Android ecosystem
is booming with devices.
You've got phones, tablets,
wearables, casts, tangos,
cardboards, and even cars.
And savvy developers know
that the most important rule
for creating stable, consistent
performance across all
of these platforms has to do
with one simple thing-- memory.
My name is Alex Danilo,
and the key to optimizing
the usage of your apps
memory, and the performance
that comes with
that, has everything
to do with wielding the
Android SDK's memory
tools like an awesome
performance ninja.
So let's begin your training.
Now, it's worth pointing
out that the ins and outs
of application memory is
much more complex than simply
allocating and releasing
objects, especially
in a garbage-collected
language, like Java.
See, garbage collection
events occur in your code
any time that resources
need to be freed,
which normally is a good thing.
But if your code isn't
utilizing memory properly,
then a flood of GC
events may occur,
eating into your performance.
You can get a sense
of how much memory
your application is using
with the memory monitor
tool inside Android Studio.
This simple tool will display a
graph that updates every second
or so, showing you how much
memory your application
is currently using,
and how much is
available to potentially use.
Each time the dark blue
section of the bar dips,
that's when a garbage
collection event has occurred,
freeing up memory
for the application.
And if you see lots of these
dips in a short period of time,
chances are that you've
got something crazy
going on in your code, that's
really eating into your app's
performance.
But sadly, the simplicity
of the memory monitor
doesn't help you track down
where this madness might
be coming from.
If we want more
fine-grained knowledge
of the state of our memory,
and what objects are actually
taking up space, we
can use a handy tool
called Heap Viewer inside DDMS.
This tool allows you to view
how much heap memory a process
is using, which is useful
in tracking down craziness
in memory during various
parts of your application's
execution.
Once you open up DDMS and
have your phone connected,
you can click on the
update heap button.
This will turn on
the profiling system
to start recording
heap information.
Once that's done,
click on the heap tab,
which will be where the
display of that data goes.
You'll now be looking at the
Java heap memory information
for the selected application.
Now notice that text
at the top of the tab--
the one that says heap
updates will happen
after every GC for this client?
Well, click on cause a
GC to update your data.
You'll see that the
data table will quickly
update, showing you what data
is currently available and alive
on the heap.
When you select one
of the data types,
the bottom panel will
update, showing you
a histogram for the
number of allocations
with a specific memory size.
For example, you can
see here that there's
over 100 objects on the heap
that are one byte arrays,
at a total size of 48 bytes.
Meanwhile, it looks like
there's a one byte array
object that's 3.8 megs.
This tool is helpful to
see what types of objects
your application has
allocated, as well as what
their sizes are on the heap.
For example, if you see three
megabytes of bitmap objects
on the heap, even though
you've destroyed that activity,
you might have a memory
leak to worry about.
But sadly, that view
doesn't tell you
where the data is being
allocated in your code.
For that, we need a new tool
called Allocation Tracker.
You can load up Android Studio,
and click on the Android tab
at the bottom of the window.
This will effectively bring
up a version of DDMS that
runs docked inside your IDE.
Once you've connected
to your device
and selected a
debuggable application,
you can click on the start
allocation tracking tab,
and then start playing around
in your application for a while.
When you're done, you can click
on the stop allocation tracking
button.
Now note, depending on how
long you've been doing stuff,
this might take a
while to complete.
So just hang out for a bit.
You'll notice that
a new tab will
appear at the top
of your IDE that
lists out all the
allocations that
occurred during the
duration of your sampling.
Each row in this view represents
an allocation that occurred.
The order column
tells you what order
this allocation happened in.
The allocated class column
tells you what type of data
was allocated--
if it's an array,
or a specific class object.
The size column tells you how
big, in bytes, the allocation
was.
The thread ID column tells
you what thread allocated
that data, and the
allocated site column
tells you what function was
responsible for allocating
that memory.
When you click on an allocation,
the bottom of the panel
will update, showing
you the full call
stack for this allocation.
This tool is super
handy for tracking down
problems like memory churn.
So if you see a bunch of
similar objects allocated,
one after the other, so
their allocation order
is close to each other,
then you found a great place
to focus on optimization.
But your performance ninja
training is far from complete.
That's why you need to check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns resources.
And don't forget to join the
Google+ community to get more
tips and tricks from other
ninjas out there in the world.
So as always, keep
calm, profile your code,
and remember-- perf matters.